[Music]
I'm malen s this is Al jazer live from
Doha we're going to take you straight to
Oslo you can see that door there that's
where the uh person is going to come out
in a moment and announce who the Nobel
Peace Prize is going to go to for this
year
2023 and uh the winners of course always
a very tightly Ed secret until the
announcement okay let's have a listen
in son sendi
aadi women life
Freedom the Norwegian Nobel committee
has decided to award the Nobel Peace
Prize for
2023 to narus muhamadi for her fight
against the oppression of women in Iran
and her fight to promote Human Rights
and freedom for
all her brave struggle has come with
tremendous personal
cost altogether the regime has arrested
her 13 times convicted her five five
times and senten her to a total of 31
years in prison and
lashes m muhamed is still in prison as I
speak in September
2022 a young Kurdish woman Masha Gina
amini was killed killed in the custody
of the Iranian moraly
police her killing triggered the largest
political demonstrations against Iran's
Theocratic regime since it came to power
in
1979 under the slogan woman life Freedom
hundreds of thousands of Iranians took
part in peaceful protests against the
authorities Brut brutality and
oppression of
women the regime cracked hard down on
the protests more than 500 demonstrators
were killed thousands were injured
including many who were blinded by
rubber bullets fired by the
police at least 20,000 people were
arrested and held in cust
y The Motto adopted by the
demonstrators woman life Freedom
suitably expresses the dedication and
work of narus
Muhammed woman she fights for women
against systematic
discrimination and
oppression life she supports women's
struggle for the right to live full and
dignified lives this struggle across
Iran has been met with persecution
imprisonment torture and even
death Freedom she fights for freedom of
expression and the right to Independence
and against runes require requiring
women to remain out of sight and cover
up their
bodies the freedom demands expressed by
demonstrators apply not only to women
but to the entire
population in the 1990s as a young
physics student narus Muhammed was
already distinguishing herself as an
advocate for equality and women wom's
rights after concluding her studies she
worked as an engineer as well as a
columnist in various reform-minded
newspapers in
2003 she became involved with the
defense of Human Rights Center in tran
an organization founded by the Nobel
Peace Prize laurate sheren
abadin in in 2011 Miss muhamed was
arrested for the first time and
sentenced to many years of imprisonment
for her efforts to assist
incarcerated activists and their
families two years later after her
release on bail Miss Muhammad immersed
herself in a campaign against the use of
death penalty Iran has long been among
the countries that execute the highest
proportion of their inhabitants
annually just since January
2022 more than
860 prisoners have been punished by
death in
Iran her activism against the death
penalty led to the rearrest of Ms
Muhammed in
2015 and to a sentence of additional
years behind
walls upon her return to prison she
began she began opposing the regime's
systematic use of torture and sexualized
violence against political prisoners and
especially women that is practiced in
Iranian
prisons last year wave of protests
became known to the political prisoners
held inside the notorious a prison in
Teran once again miss muhamadi assumed
leadership from prison she expressed
support for the demonstrators and
organized solidarity actions among her
fellow
inmates the prison Authority responded
by imposing even stricter conditions
Miss muhamed was prohibited from
receiving calls and
visitors she nevertheless managed to
smuggle out an article which the New
York Times published on the oneye
anniversary of Mara Gina Amin's killing
the message
was the more of us they lock up up the
stronger we
become from
captivity Miss muhamadi has helped to
ensure that the protests have not ebed
out narus muhamadi is a woman a human
rights Advocate and a freedom fighter in
awarding her this year's Nobel Peace
Prize the Norwegian Nobel committee
wishes to honor her courageous fight for
human rights freedom and democracy in
Iran this year's Peace Prize also
recognizes the hundreds of thousands of
people who in the preceding year have
demonstrated against the Theocratic
regime's policies of discrimination
and oppression targeting
women only by embracing equal rights for
all can the world achieve the fraternity
between
nations um that Alfred Nobel sought to
promote the award to narus Muhammed
follows a long
tradition in which the Norwegian Nobel
committee has awarded the Peace Prize to
those working to advance social justice
human rights and
democracy these are important
preconditions for lasting
peace thank
you madam chair um what impact do you
hope that this price will have on the
situation in
Iran
this prize is okay there you have it the
Nobel Peace Prize for 2023 has been
announced it's been awarded to the
Iranian women's rights campaigner nagas
Muhammed you can see a picture there the
committee we heard there from Barrett
ree Anderson the chair of the Nobel
committee saying that she received the
prize for a fight against the oppression
of women in Iran and all her efforts for
promoting Human Rights and freedom for
all Muhammed has been in jail since 2016
and has long advocated to abolish the
death penalty in Iran she's also been
elected the president of the executive
committee of the National Council of
Peace in Iran let's get more on this we
can speak to Henrik oal he joins us from
Oslo he is the director of the peace
Research Institute thank you for your
time uh I was actually going through
your own short list a little earlier and
you've picked it haven't
you miss miss uh NIS Muhammed was top of
your
list she was and and we have been
expecting a human rights prize this year
and especially for women's rights and
this is a not a surprise and it's a huge
um it's a very important priz and and
one that is really celebrating the
achievements of Human Rights Defenders
and specifically of course Women rights
defenders in Iran which has been a very
troubled country it has indeed uh just
to take a step back I mean how how do
how do they go about uh picking a
winner so there is a a large number of
uh of eligible nominators and those
members of of national parliaments it
could be professors of of a lot of
different Sciences uh so they're
receiving more than 350 nominations each
year uh and the nomination deadline is
in January and right now uh the the uh
the way that this works is that the
committee is uh vetting candidates
carefully uh they're considering
different domains and this year human
rights uh was on top of their agenda and
uh and uh it's um been both expected
since there are no sort of other major
developments in in terms of of uh um uh
peace negotiations and and um uh and
weapons agreements but this year uh with
the human rights um being uh a an
expected prize area the price to Iran is
is certainly one that that will make a
huge difference and will I think
resonate well beyond the context of Iran
yeah tell us a little bit more about
naras uh she is a campaign and Iranian
campaigner she's been in jail I believe
since on and off since 2011 she's in uh
one of the more notorious prisons in
Iran for uh I believe spreading
propaganda I mean you you touch on it
but tell us a bit more about how
significant it is that she now receives
this particular
prize yeah absolutely she's she's
currently in Evan prison in Teran and
and has been for a long time she's been
sentenced a number of times in the past
for her contributions for her activism
she's member of the of the human rights
Defenders Center uh which which was
established by shiren abadi the 2003
Prize winner uh so she uh is is uh
contributing to sort of a long tradition
uh of Human Rights Defenders she's
worked not only for women's rights in
Iran she's worked against the death
penalty she's worked against corruption
so she's working for human rights
broadly and and that's also something
that the committee is emphasizing in the
announcement that that she has worked
for human rights for everyone in Iran uh
and so this is going to be of course a
huge boost to her Center to the work
that she and others have been doing at
the at Human Rights um Defender Center
and one that is putting human rights
abuses in Iran on the map yes and of
course not not just the people uh that
she works with but the women of Iran who
have been fighting for their cause uh so
long especially since the death of
Masa exactly and there have been
hundreds of people killed in the streets
of Iran during the protest since since
2022 so this is a um a prize that is
also focusing on on the contributions or
the the sacrifices I should say of of
young people in Iran that that we've
seen in in most recent years and and
this is of course an important way of uh
of um uh of underlining um their
sacrifices and and the huge challenges
that human rights activists in Iran are
operating under Henrik uh I hope this
question is not too left field for you
but given the state of the world today
and where we're at in terms of the the
different countries does giving out an
award for peace seem a little
fruitless yeah we are now living through
times that are less peaceful that we've
seen in in many many years and so uh in
one way you could say that you know
awarding a Peace Prize now is is more
difficult but I think it is more
important than ever to highlight all of
the good contributions that we see all
over the world and human rights um
activists are of course uh making those
contributions putting their life and
health uh on the line and and making uh
exceptionally important uh contributions
to respecting uh human rights democracy
all over the world and so this is um
this is an opportunity uh in my view to
highlight all of those important ways of
of pursuing peace thank you for your
time Henrik alal the director of Peace
Research Institute joining us there from
Oslo and just to recap the Nobel Peace
prize of 2023 has been awarded to the
Iranian women's rights campaigner nagas
muhamed there she is pictured the
committee said she received the prize
for a fight against the oppression of
women in
Iran